peu
non
de venger de l'autre françois vous
l'attendez souvent oui toutes les
semaines oui presse c'est pourquoi parce
qu'on vit ensemble à lyon et rennes
d'heure d'abord qu'est ce qui représente
pour vous les symboles non parce que
j'adore le plus dynamique et le plus
jeune je rejoins de magnifiques trop
vieux pour vous c'est très bien et très
jeune elle agit là pour vous attendra
pour moi il s'agit vous êtes toutes
amoureuses de lui oui
ah ouais
chimène
[Musique]
une pression ça fait d'avoir 4 millions
de femmes ont cette agréable ça soit des
fans que ce soit d'une façon générale
quand on me dit tiens quelqu'un qui
t'aime bien vraiment même si à la limite
tu te dis il a intérêt à dire ça même
assez extrême limite du 10 mai ça crie
quand même plaisir qu'ils sont obligés
de me le dire
alors quand on dit quelqu'un t'aime bien
ça fait toujours plaisir chez moi je
reprends toujours et aucune comparaison
bien sûr que j'en pense j'ai un chien et
un chat et tous les deux mains d'avoir
quand j'arrive on y arrive que le chan
la remue pas parce qu'en général c'est
parce qu'il n'est pas content le chat
vient ronronner etc
alors je les aime parce qu'il m'aime je
dire c'est élémentaire comme sentiment
alors quand les gens tu aimes bien on
utilise un bien aussi puis ça fait
plaisir que les gens admirent
j'aime pas que le transforme truc qu'il
est vachement efféminé et vous vous êtes
fan
oui beaucoup rivages avez-vous 13 ans et
demi non mes 14 ans dans une semaine
depuis combien de temps vous aimez
claude haut depuis 4 5 ans qu'est ce que
vous feriez pour lui pas l'impossible en
tout cas non oui très fan depuis combien
de temps
et puis 12 13 ans depuis le ses débuts
vous pensez qu'il a vieilli au nom est
toujours resté le même toujours le jeune
je le connais depuis toujours et
vraiment il est formidable
extraordinaire qu'est ce que vous aimez
chez lui son style son site le
perfection absolument tout il est
parfait du point de vue de tous tout au
tout vraiment je crois que c'est des
gens qui sont imbéciles et c'est abusé
là il sait manipuler les gens mais d'une
façon forme il a vraiment c'est les gens
qui sont comme celui qui est merveilleux
[Musique]